we encountered some problems so we
wanted to integrate dysfunction two
times sine squared of X from 0 to PI and
through engineering or few mathematics
we realize that this should be part and
what we did is that we ran the code that
would integrate is through multi-column
iteration and we got one so there is
some problem there is some insufficient
knowledge that we have that we have to
remedy in some way so why don't we take
a look at another example we should
really know what we did wrong
so let's integrate this under little bit
difficult function from 1 to 0 obviously
this is x squared over 2 and the
brackets show you that we have to
substitute this form onto 5 what we get
in the end is 12 now
let's go Monte Carlo integration let's
pretend that we have the very structure
as we invite to neurotically so I think
three completely random samples of this
function what does it mean that I will
iron it f of X at 1 now if I evaluate
this X at 1 I obviously that I evaluated
at 3 and I also get back three so I have
three samples now and what I do is are
simply average time so this is 1 plus 3
plus 5 over 3 the end result is complete
but it shouldn't be that right because
the end result through analytic
integration is exactly 4 times them so
something is definitely wrong with this
multicolor integration scheme so what we
know is that 3 is exactly 1 4 of 12
so we see that there is a difference
five of the factor of four and if you
take a closer look at the integration
domain then we will see that 4 is
exactly the size so just a miracle here
if we don't this is why I go to look at
the problem and to fold it you will see
more people and what this is more like
the engineering way of solving things
you don't know how to derive the full
and correct solution but you see that
there's the factor of four for exercise
of the integration domain or why don't
we multiply with that and see what
happens and obviously it works so you
can multiply with the size of the
integration domain we get the result
that we're looking for so let's change
the port I multiply the previous
function with the integration domain
which is from 0 to PI and this is what I
want to find and obviously I will get PI
as a result which is
now this is great and this looks very
simple
and apparently this technique seems to
work but we still don't really know what
is happening here so we should use some
black magic or mathematics if you will
to see what is going on on the road so
imagine that we sample a function with
the uniform distribution on zero path
what does it mean I have an interval
from 0 to 5 and I generate random
numbers on it and every single number
has the very same probability so this
function would look like 1 over 5
regardless of X in the parameter because
it doesn't matter which part of the
domain I choose it will have the same
probability chosen now what we are
essentially doing is integrating a
function f of X multiplied by this
sampling probability why because imagine
that some regions of the function would
have zero probability to be sampled so
imagine that I'm integrating from 0 to
PI but I will only take samples from 0
to 2 so there is a region in the
function that are never going to visit
and I don't integrate this point so that
that's one intuition the other intuition
is that if I draw samples magnet uniform
distribution but with a different
distribution that in the average device
compute some regions of the faction will
be over because I have a higher chance
of something goes so what we are doing
is multiplying is f of X with a sample
probability P of X now this P of X is in
this case to 1 over pi the uniform
distribution which is obviously a
constant so get out of I in the wrong
and in the end we have the fact the
integral of the function over pi but
this is not what I'm looking for I just
want to
great the function itself so I need to
make this pie disappear so I have this
one over pilot to buyer what do I need
to multiply with to get only this
function what should the question mark
be excellent exactly so I just killed
this one over PI x which is this P of X
sampling distribution and if you take a
look done yes this is also the size of
the integration so this is a bit more
rigorous but before us way to understand
what is going on this is through
interrogation not just empty little
stuff what should i multiply with we
know a bit more about what is happening
I have a sample distribution that I need
to get bigger so if I have to 1 over PI
multiplier I got the one incorrectly and
if I lose this scalar multiplier that
I'm looking for then I will get to the
correct solution
let's examine the whole thing a bit for
deeply different angles I would like to
show you how to solve the same problem
so super big probability theory we can
we have an expected value this is what
we're looking for what isn't expected
value the expected value means that
there is a value of something and there
is a probability of getting these values
so let's take the expected value of the
dice for how does it work I can roll
from 1 to 6 and they all have the same
probability overall the same probability
1/6 so the values are 1 2 up to 6 and
the probabilities for all the same 1/6
and if I have to say that this says that
the expected value of the dice roll 325
well this means that if I mean if I
don't need to guess what the next high
school would be then this would be the
best value in order to minimize the
error from the expected outcome now if
we would like to compute the expected
value of something that this means that
I think the values that is something can
take and I multiply it with the
probabilities for this event for
instance it is impossible to roll 7 with
the dice so theoretically you could put
as the something the 7 in there but it
would have zero probability therefore we
do not show up yourself and this is the
discrete case for the continuous case we
don't really need to do anything very
serious we just change the summation to
integration so we are not using the
discrete sum but we are integrating
continuous functions and then using
continuous subject
now let's introduce is notation what I'm
looking for is the expected value of
this function f of X after an N amount
of samples because the quality of
integration you need to add more and
more samples to get more info now what
this means is f is the something and P
is the sampling distribution what we can
do is that we can create a discrete sum
that takes samples of this function and
then multiplies with the size of the
domain and obviously since we are taking
a sum you need to divide by F is the
more sample and the number of cells the
more samples we take from the function
the larger the number you get so this is
the averaging part now you have to take
a look at always keep looking at the
relevant quantities so the expected
value of this f of X it doesn't mean
that in the integration I multiply it
with this something probability and on
the right side in the monte carlo
destiny i will have the same quantity as
on the left side so if i am looking for
the expected value of x then i will
sample f of x now
if you have if you take a look at that
you can see that this is just an
approximation this is not exactly
interval that we're looking for but
there is a multitude of theorems in
computer science that show you that if
you could use an infinite amount of
samples then you would approach the
actual and most courses or Monte Carlo
integration show you different ways of
proving this but this is not the this is
what is happening exactly very with it
why this is happening you remember
seeing this family that we sampled would
always do and also you can see that if
you have a lot of samples you will get
to the destination of the curve now
let's try to use different samples to do
something in a few minutes you will see
why this would be a good idea in some
cases so I would like to integrate this
f of X and I am now doing the
transformation that is the identity
transformation I didn't do anything for
my hat effects I multiplied by P of X
and then I divided by so this is almost
like the scalar multiplier and that I
divided the same other I get the very
same thing but if I would like to write
that this is the expected value of
something then this may look a bit
different because F over P is the
something and P of X is the preserve in
power distribution so what we have now
is the expected value of F
and the question is what is the Monte
Carlo estimator for this and what we
concluded in the previous slides that
this should be the very same quantity as
what I see in the expected value so I
will be something F over so not only
something F I'm sampling F over the
arbitrarily chosen probability
distribution now there are some good
readings on how to do this well and why
this is useful so if you would like to
know more about this please read some of
these talking us they are really
relevant and that's because I've seen
lots of muscle where we can guides on
the integration and very long time to
find something that has the quality that
I should give up for other people to
study now let's solve the actual example
that we had previously with this formula
so f over the x field so I am still
integrating only F and the sampling
distribution was this 2 times sine
square X this was the function that we
wanted to integrate and one of our files
or something is two different
probability so uniform distribution over
1/2 so and here in fact the integral of
the original function so I am looking
for the expected value that's F over P
so I'm going to sample in my phone F
over P let's put this in source code if
you look here I now divide by the
sampling distribution
so it's one over B minus a so this means
105 be ready this age should have been 0
in this case so I apologize for the
defenses of the code I put the 2.5 in
there because if you always begin it's
always 0 then you may write a code that
works for integration from zero to
something but not one to something so
this is a cool thing to check if you
have deployment to this so I apologize
this aid should be zero but if you
compute the actual result that you would
be looking for then you will get your
own pipe so this is the app the first
term in the common line 36 and after the
division we have okay wonderful so this
works and from multiple angles we now
understand how exactly this thing is
working now if you provide the goods
want account integration routine and you
saw the rendering equation which is what
you wanna see is that as you add more
samples you will see first really noisy
image and that's as you have more and
more samples this noise will slowly and
if you if you think back is a previous
lecture of mine we have talked about
over and other estimations of the
integral and this is exactly what shows
up also in images we are trying to
sample function I would like to be
interested in the radiance but as I have
more and more samples before I converge
I will get values that are larger than
the actual intensities and I will get
values that are smaller so this is what
shows up visually as moles so what you
are looking for is always this samples
per pixel
mattering
and when you have a noisy image you
would need to know how many samples I
have used for pixel and if it's still
moist time you need to add more samples
this is also some visualization on on
the evolution of the village after
hundreds and then 100,000 samples
depending on the algorithm these
multiple ways of solving venerating
theory you could have smarter algorithms
that take longer to complete one sample
because they are doing some smart magic
that this would mean that you would need
less samples per pixel to engage the
converse damage and the first algorithm
that we do studied it is actually the
naive algorithm has both operating and
this usually is tremendous amount of
samples to compute an image but since it
is a simple algorithm you can use your
GPU or CPU to dish out a lot of samples
for pixels in every cycle now a bit of
the beauty break this is what we can get
if we come in such a hot day so this was
regular black sweater and some recent
example does anyone of the disease
okay top of the people okay excellent
so this is actually Margaery Tyrell from
the game of Thrones and if anyone tells
me and spoilers i play on that page okay
so please and this is actuality because
the game of horse is running obviously
we all dr. show and there's also skin
being rendered so there's tons of
subsurface scattering and you can solve
this with a single actress so that we
will keep together the theoretical part
the second half of this lecture and that
will be implemented on extraction so
when I see renders like this what I feel
is only comparable to religious
spiritual water it is is absolutely
amazing that we can compute something
like this using only mathematics these
very simple things that I have shown and
the other really cool thing is that we
are arriving these algorithms we are
creating products that these these
algorithms and these are given to world
class artists who are just as beautiful
artists as we are engineers and they are
also giving it their best to create more
and more fill two models and we can work
together to create stuff like that so
this is absolutely